the flux may be over
but it kind of left a mess so we've got
pieces to pick up here
[Music]
[Music]
now i had always been planning to do an
overview review for doctor who flux i do
it pretty much every time there's a new
series sometimes it is a little more
than just a ranking of the episodes
but uh i didn't know what form it was
going to take this time knowing going in
that it was supposed to be serialized
i'm not sure i necessarily would have
called that it was going to take the
form of
how did this happen
but here we are
now a couple things before we get
started firstly if you like doctor who
flux and you think that it worked
i love you
and i am jealous of you i wish i had
that experience
i didn't
and what i'm going to be talking about
is largely my perception of the thing
i'm not picking it apart because i know
what the general consensus is i'm trying
well everyone says it's bad let's talk
about why i don't know if everyone's
saying that it's bad i actually don't
dive as much into the general fan
consensus or critical discourse about
these things as you might think i do i
do check out some reviews by some other
people here on youtube who i like but i
usually do that like a month after the
things aired because i want to kind of
have my own thoughts cleansed and out of
me before i do that
so
i don't know
if this thing failed as hard for other
people as it did for me i know there are
definitely some people for whom it
didn't
because i have to moderate my own dang
comments section
however i did notice a little bit of
shift
in the tone of the comments defending
this series as time went on because
right from the first episode which i
didn't like um people were telling me
why are you complaining that
everything's unexplained it's serialized
missing the point that i was trying to
make which was
regardless of whether we're getting more
stuff later this seems like a lot to
pile into six episodes and it's not
balanced well right off the bat
at least it wasn't for me
now those criticisms stuck around but
started dwindling as time went on um
with village of the angels i was just
basically called a hater as if i went
and wanted to hate everything despite
the fact that i genuinely liked war of
the santarans but whatever
but by the end
by the time the vanquishers
was out and my review was up
i'm not going to say there weren't
people still defending it saying that
they liked it there were
there seemed to be fewer of them
notably less vocal and the tone had gone
from i think this is amazing and
fantastic
to a bit more along the lines of
look i understand the problems that you
see but i still liked it there were
still some people claiming that it was
great on its face but there was like
three of those as opposed to the
cavalcade of them that started out so
the impression that i got at least from
my own comment section
not sure how good a sample that is
but just based off that
enthusiasm for this started to dwindle
and fear of not sticking the landing
started to go up and
i
the impression i have is that more
people think it fell apart than thought
it worked again that's my impression
this is still what i want to talk about
because to me
this fell apart almost immediately
and i was trying to think of the best
way to summarize
how it fell apart and how early it fell
apart but you know what how about we
just start with a little bit of a rapid
fire round on questions that i had that
did not ever get addressed to my
satisfaction and i'll also point out
like the degree to which any of this
matters varies some of these are i will
freely admit kind of on the petty side
but my point here is more
how many of these there are
why was a jour hidden as a normal human
whereas swarm was kept locked up in this
special prison for millennia and if
she's been in prison for as long as he
has
how the heck did that work did she like
become her own daughter or what why is
her imprisonment this different from his
why do azure and swarm bother to kidnap
diane because they go out of their way
to do that they single her out they know
her by name
why
they pay no special attention to her
later now she serves a plot function
inside passenger to be the only one left
who can tell vinder what's going on but
why the heck is she the only one left
why was she collected in the first place
and then why was she spared who is the
grand serpent and what is he trying to
accomplish now i know the immediate
answer he is trying to help diminish the
influence of unit so that the santorins
can make their move but
why
what is he looking to actually gain out
of this especially given that when we
first meet him in vinder's flashback he
seems to be in a seat of immense power
so what the heck is he doing on earth
doing little weird jobs for the
centaurons obviously he's getting
something out of it but
what and how does that add to the power
we already saw him wielding why would he
step away from that to do this what the
heck happened to the angel in clare's
head are we meant to presume that it's
gone why was claire left behind is the
angel still in her head if so
how is that ever gonna be addressed if
it's not and the angel was extracted
along with the doctor
well then how does that actually impact
claire if she's been carrying this thing
for as long as was implied speaking of
village of the angels or rather the
follow-up what the heck happened to
peggy town gets put back and peggy is
just left there because it's not her
time and everybody else in the town was
gone and not that i'm saying they should
have devoted a huge chunk of time to
this but you know one little line just a
little bit of dialogue between the other
three is their gallivanting around the
planet just to cover that
i don't think that's too much to ask
what is the purpose of division
because
what we get from techn is that at this
point division appears to exist largely
just in opposition to the doctor which
immediately makes it vastly
uninteresting because now it's
completely reactionary and it seems to
exist only because of her which i feel
kind of inherently makes it less
interesting plus it's already been done
with the entire thing that went on with
the headless monks and mata kavarian and
the silence the doctor who has not that
far back in the past done the story of
something horrible exists just to oppose
the doctor and i'm not entirely sure it
worked that time either okay so that's
what division is doing now it initiates
the flux basically deciding to destroy
the entire universe
because the doctor is too much of a
force for good division created the flux
because you're scared of me not scared
weary
except they also say and offer the
doctor the chance to come to the new
universe if you're destroying the entire
universe because of her presence why
would you offer her a place in the new
universe aren't you gonna have to do all
this again rejoin me
come with us into the next universe into
the beyond but the thing that's really
driving me nuts that's what division
does now what was division before
what was the doctor doing for them what
was their mission and the closest thing
we get is they fight on behalf of space
against time but that's really weird and
abstract and hard to get your head
around and i'm not entirely sure it's
presented in a way that makes much sense
beyond just
okay yeah i guess
what what the heck happened to
everything that the flux destroyed
we've already seen so much damage done
we've seen planets ripped apart we've
seen things destroyed the ood points out
how much has already been destroyed this
is all that remains the first flux event
destroyed many galaxies the earth was
spared by this whole thing with the
lupari was the rest of the solar system
destroyed do we still have a sun now
there's a number of possible answers to
this there's a number of things seeded
that maybe could be the answer swarm
talks about how their plan is to
actually destroy the universe recreate
it and destroy it again so maybe if they
caught it at the right time they caught
it right at the start of a new universe
being created and they stopped the flux
early enough that it doesn't destroy
anything other than all the fleets and
then gets caught up in passenger maybe
there's stuff that maybe the ooh did
something to reverse this there was a
theory going in that everything was just
going to move over to the new universe
that doesn't appear to have happened but
like there's any number of possible
explanations but there's also the
possibility that we're just not going to
address the fact that massive swathes of
the universe are just gone just gone
and
we don't have a firm answer as to why
that isn't the case which leaves us in a
position where i'm just going
why are you all so happy
right now
at the end of this like you're just
gonna jaunt off on another adventure
what then there's the whole thing with
time because time is now a force in
opposition to space which
i don't think that's how anything works
but okay
and but it's also a planet
but it's also a person
who takes the form of whoever they're
speaking with what does it want
what is it doing
why did it wipe out azure and swarm it
seemed to imply that they somehow failed
it so it obviously has a plan
and an agenda
i mean i could just point out it's a
very stupid villain thing to wipe out
your assets just because they didn't
fully accomplish what you wanted them to
so
it's got all this stuff going on but i'm
like
why what is it that you want
now i've seen some people in my comments
already point out things like well
that's hardly new look at the black
guardian look at fenrik look at all the
stuff from classic except that you know
i'm going to sit i'm going to be the
contrarian sit back and go yeah and it
wasn't good there either
i don't really like curse of fenwick
partly for that reason i don't really
like the guardians
because of that reason
i like the general idea of things that
are
too powerful for us to fully wrap our
heads around or for the doctor to ever
fully be able to get on top of or have
any hope of defeating if she or he or
they or whichever form the doctor has
can't even comprehend what they're
trying to do
but
that's a fine line to walk and it rarely
works for me more often than not it
makes me bored of the villain because i
don't know what it is they're trying to
accomplish
if anything like for me it worked in
something like the impossible planet and
the satan pit because it was evoking a
something that i did understand i.e the
devil but also kept it just vague enough
while giving us a lot of tangible
details in the way that it interacted
and manipulated everybody so i felt like
i got to know the beast in a way that
i don't understand this time
thing
now while i wanted to float those
questions out there just to show kind of
the jumble of things brought up not
addressed ignored or were addressed in a
way that i freaking missed
i don't actually want people to go down
in the comments section and give me a
litany of answers to all these questions
i'm just sort of doing that as an
initial setup to sort of show this was
not done especially smoothly and even
people again who liked it often when
they were in my comment section saying
well okay you asked this here's what i
think
and there would be two or three of those
per episode well at minimum
and they were almost all different
i it feels like hell bent and the hybrid
all over again where the people who like
it
agree that it definitely means something
and it's not vegan unanswered but they
can't seem to agree on what that is
which i find
pretty telling but for me at this point
the more pressing question is
how did this happen
and no i'm not just gonna cop to the
easy lazy
answer of well gymnal just sucks because
no
it's not that simple it can't be
regardless of what you think of what
he's done for doctor who a lot of which
i haven't cared for the man is still a
professional television writer he knows
how to work in this medium specifically
he knows how to work in serialization
the thing that he is best known for his
most highly praised piece of work is
broadchurch which is completely a
serialized story he knows how to pace
things across a serialized story over
multiple episodes so what
the hell
happened
well
i did ask that question in my review of
the last episode and i have now actually
gotten some sourcing done
that gives um
some indications as to what happened so
there was a quote from chibnall uh that
was taken around the time that filming
started noting that they had a shorter
season and what he said was you know
because of things going on with the
coveted restrictions and our shooting
schedule we are only going to have eight
episodes as opposed to 11. now don't
focus on that number of eight because
since he compared it to 11 that means
that he is counting the special
uh that comes afterwards because you
know series 12 and series 11 had 10
episodes and a special that's 11
episodes so if he's saying well we're
gonna have eight episodes and we and
he's counting the special
that means that he was expecting to have
a seven episode series
plus the special
now
it doesn't sound like a lot
when you think well they're only missing
one episode
it can mean more than you think
especially in a serialized format where
part of how you balance everything is to
have the ongoing story spread across the
episodes even when individual episodes
are dealing with something smaller if
you lose the places where you build that
connective tissue
or suddenly have to take connective
tissue intended to be spread across more
episodes and cram it into fewer it
starts to feel rushed it starts to feel
cobbled together starts to feel really
ramshackle and the timing of that quote
i think is the most important thing
because as i said at the time he was
quoted at that shooting had started
so that means
during production
they
thought they had a they had at least one
more episode than they ended up getting
in the end
now the specifics of this are a little
vegas probably a combination of things
we know that ed heim was originally
going to write an episode for this
series ultimately that did not happen so
it's easy to assume that whatever he was
working on was what got chucked exactly
what that is
you know i i could look more into it but
it kind of doesn't matter because even
if he was doing a more self-contained
story like war for the santa
warf i've been saying that repeatedly
war of the santarans or village of the
angels there still would have been
overarching stuff going on that now
suddenly had to be crammed into
everything else because even those two
episodes that are more or less
standalone that we still have tie
increasingly into the overall story war
of the santarans is pretty
self-contained up until the tail end
village of the angels its own conclusion
to the immediate situation is actually
heavily tied into the overarching story
so that one's even more intertwined now
i heard some things that heim was
working on an episode that was going to
feature jack harkness and that the bad
press around john barrem was the reason
that didn't happen i couldn't verify
that that's possible i think another
thing that is at least as likely if not
more likely is the fact that they had a
set amount of time to get these shot the
thing to remember is
they were planning to get
eight episodes shot they ended up if we
again if we count the special only
getting seven
now that's not a matter of we're
scheduling you for shooting eight
episodes the bbc is telling them this is
how much time we're giving you to shoot
for production
you figure out how many episodes you can
do
during that it's distinctly possible
that the restrictions that were put in
place for shooting
in the time of covid
caused everything to take longer and
they may have just had to cut it because
they didn't have the time anymore to
shoot one more episode than we ended up
getting and i suspect covid restrictions
were actually part of the problem with
some of the wonky editing that's going
on as well because especially by the end
things jump around a lot like i i need
to single out this thing because this
jarred the heck out of me so we very
suddenly go from here
to deal with claire
which is already kind of sudden and
jarring like okay but then all of a
sudden we get this shot and whoa oh my
god kate god you scared me i had no idea
you were even there like it's really
weird but it's the kind of thing that
results when you don't have time to
shoot all the footage you need and you
aren't able to go back and do re-shoots
this is the exact kind of thing that
happens
and we can probably thank the pandemic
for how many times characters are simply
isolated in their own shots and not have
multiple actors appearing within shot
but my point in all this
is that
it really does look like
they were having to adjust and correct
for losing an episode
while production was already in motion
which
when i brought up this possible point uh
when i talked about that last episode i
hadn't really considered in my mind i
had thought because i'd heard the things
you know they were going to have more
episodes than they ended up getting
which i've now confirmed but
at the time i thought well he either
knew going in how many episodes he was
going to have and he didn't write it
properly he being chibnall that does not
appear to be the case well you could
make the argument that this story
wouldn't work even with more episodes
but that's a hypothetical i don't want
to deal with it
the other thing that i had floated was
he was told he was gonna have fewer
episodes but they wouldn't that wouldn't
have happened so close to production
that he wouldn't have time to adjust for
them well no it actually appears to have
happened during production whether it
was a bbc mandate or it was something he
and his production team realized after
the first block of shooting i'm going to
talk about the shooting blocks in a
minute too i don't know but either way
it leaves them in a situation where
they're having to scramble and not
having the time to readjust everything
especially because a lot of it is
already being shot
my big overriding criticism of this
thing from the get-go but it compounded
as time went on was how many of these
plot lines don't really need to be there
for the sake of the overall story and in
a longer series i would think more than
one episode longer but just in general
in a longer series with a little more
breathing room
the plots that are present
wouldn't feel quite so stacked on to
each other because we'd have a little
bit more time to explore these angles
and maybe have more time to connect them
but even if you don't connect them when
you have breathing room it can just add
a nice flavor to take some time to do
something like get to know vender and
bell a little bit better
and things like that whereas when you
are at a breakneck pace because
everything is going on at once
those feel like the kind of characters
you cut if they ultimately don't matter
them the grand serpent the stuff with
diana being kidnapped probably most of
the williamson things honestly if you
really could start from the beginning
and know how few episodes you have you
probably scrap one of the standalone
episodes war of the santarans or village
of the angels and then rework that into
something that is pushing forward the
overarching story first and foremost but
the problem is
the nature of the shooting blocks
because
these were shot in two separate filming
blocks
the first block
saw the filming of episodes one
two and four
and then the second block was episodes
three
five and
six what that means is
if as i suspect
chibnall and the production team
realized during the the shooting of the
first block
that they weren't that they were going
to be short an episode
that means
that they were stuck with whatever was
already locked in
for that first shooting block
and they would have they could only
finagle the other ones
and that means you can't excise plot
lines because
pretty much every plot line is
introduced
within those episodes that were shot
within the first shooting block and
while i didn't particularly like episode
1 or episode 4 i will admit they are
tighter and less chaotic messes
than episodes 3 5 and 6 are the
nature of those and how
just thrown together as if they're
desperately trying to tie their
shoelaces while mid-run
[Music]
they kind of were
that feel comes from
we are locked into all this stuff that's
already shooting and we can't alter the
shooting schedule that much because it's
already under all these restrictions and
everybody's time is precious time is
money we're actually better off leaving
those shooting plans at intact as much
as possible and only altering what comes
what's going to get shot after
which because the last two episodes were
part of the second shooting block means
that the whole thing starts to fall
apart
as we get to the finish line
this is not entirely chibnall's fault
the storyline's being done
he picked them
he decided what stories were going to
happen he decided there were going to be
this many
but those are decisions that he made
back when he probably didn't realize
exactly how restrictive the shooting was
going to be
and he thought he was going to have more
episodes to do it in and so while the
overall plot and uh one other thing that
i'm going to point out in a minute which
is kind of my last hang up that i want
to deal with
those are things that can be laid at
chibnall's feet
but a lot of the final result of this
was stuff that couldn't be helped
it was the shooting restrictions from
the pandemic it's the fact that he
didn't realize until partway into
production that he was not going to get
as many episodes as he thought he was
and then having to try and readjust just
the back half plus you know one episode
in the middle of that first shooting
block that that's all he's gonna have to
tinker with to try and have this all
make sense
which is why things like episode three
once upon time is an episode that left a
lot of people very confused as the
doctor and companions are spread across
these timeline events but also like
they're sort of weird and warped and
between that and the three doctors thing
later on and how many things go
unexplored and techtayoon shows up to
like make a big deal out of the memories
and set that up and then that ultimately
goes nowhere and she dies it all feels
like it was done in a panic
and i kind of suspect that it was
and i think the only reason people
didn't fully cordon on to that sooner
is because of episode four which again
i didn't like but lots of people did and
it is tighter than
episodes three five and six
so if you're watching it as it airs
episode one
is setting everything up i would argue
poorly but obviously it worked better
for some other people episode two i
genuinely like i think is really good
episode three
feels a bit like whoa that okay
they're throwing a lot at us and i'm not
entirely sure i followed it but then on
episode later episode four everything
seems tight and planned again but that
third episode that was the first kink in
the armor that
is uh something that was shot in
conjunction with episodes five and six
where it's all going to come unraveled
now the one last thing that i want to
bring up that drives me
nuts about this is something that i'm
going to lay at chibnall's feet
and that is the fob watch
and the doctor's memories i don't have a
problem
of that being set up i kind of
complained a little bit about the time
like that's not how we've seen fob
watches work
whatever we can change how they work it
can be modified whatever but we set up
this thing of her memories that she's
been chasing she's kind of had captain
jack's mission that also never fully got
resolved back from torchwood of the idea
of he was missing a year of his life
and there's her answers
but ultimately she is going to
reject them they're not going to be
stolen away from her but she's going to
go
i don't need to know this
now on paper
that is a good thing
because the doctor
is her own person regardless of what
parts of her past she does or doesn't
remember
here's why that doesn't work though
that was the same arc she had in the
timeless children
have you ever been limited by who you
were before
that just sounds like me talking the
whole thing with the master revealing
all this to her
and it shaking her
and then the fugitive doctor snapping
her out of it
the entire concept of that was
it doesn't matter what memories you've
lost you know who you are now
so we've done this beat already
and if you're about to tell me well
they're just reinforcing it
it's self-defeating in that case because
if the doctor truly came to terms with
that idea why was she pursuing cavanesta
to try and track down
everything she could about division
because that proves that she hasn't
actually gotten over it and she hasn't
come to grips with it which in and of
itself is also okay she can have a
moment of catharsis and revelation to
get her out of the situation she was in
the timeless children and then backslide
when she's forced to just sit around and
have these thoughts invasive in her mind
that would work too
but to have that be the case and then
have her come to the exact same
conclusion we already saw her come to at
the end of the last full series
is just infuriating you're spinning your
wheels at that point
spinning it on a decent point a decent
emotional core but we've done this
already
and for it to happen again now means
that it was undone between then and now
and then you didn't even undo it to do
something different you undid it to do
the exact same thing again
i kind of brush it off but i do question
how
much this would have worked for me even
without the cover shooting restrictions
even with at least one more episode to
play with
i do still kind of question that because
i'm not sure how much i like this story
but i absolutely have to admit that a
lot of the issues with the execution
aren't really the faults
of the people involved in production
which
that's rare for me i don't let people
off the hook very often
and i'm only partially letting them off
the hook now
but i think it is worth keeping in mind
if like me you don't think flux worked
it's not as simple as because chibnall
sucks
that's reductive and unhelpful
and those are my thoughts on what the
flux happened here
if you want to support this kind of
content
please consider supporting my patreon
but even if you don't do that
i want to hear your thoughts on all this
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it
the usual stuff like share and subscribe
they help me out as well
but i'm not going to tell you what to do
because
at the end of the day you are the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]